what's up guys I'm Walter Bernays biak
and welcome to another 90s edition of
top 5 kickback grab some pork butts
because today we're counting down the
top 5 best Cartoon Network original
shows from the same decade that channel
came to problem after the great response
from you guys on last week's top 5 best
90s Nicktoons I decided to say thank you
by putting the power in your hands this
top 5 is the result of a Twitter poll I
put up asking what should be covered
next on top 5 more polls will be going
up on there soon so if you want your
voice heard on what I should cover next
make sure you follow me on Twitter at
awesome underscore Walter I'm going to
do so much I'm a little swimmer I'm
gonna do some uh-oh
[Music]
ed admit he started in 1999 with his
first season and went on in the 2000 to
become a pretty popular show it
culminated in a 90-minute TV movie in
2009 the show centers around the three
Ed's with Eddie as they're scheming
leader he often forces his friends to
engage in plots to make money off the
other local kids so the trio can
purchase giant jawbreakers which they
are obsessed with ed many is one of the
longest-running shows Cartoon Network
has ever put out creator Danny Anthony G
originally pitched the show to both
Cartoon Network and Nickelodeon I can't
see Eddie and Eddie as a Nick show could
you I just think it's got its own unique
tone that would not have fit in over
there at the time the three Ed's and how
they worked off each other was the
foundation of why the show was so
successful it seemed like a basic
formula with a smart one the dumb one
and the leader but this cartoon made
those archetypes really work for it a
longevity of the series is testament to
that oh well do me a couple three we're
waiting very welcome McPhee now it's an
important show because in 1999 Cartoon
Network had a few very successful shows
but Eddie and Eddie helped bring CN into
the new century and became a mainstay
I'm going to go find one of those jaw
breakers number four
[Music]
Cartoon Network owes most of the success
of its initial original series content
to this show it was the launching pad
for many cartoons that eventually became
their own shows including Courage the
Cowardly Dog codename kids next door and
even featured very early versions of
characters from Seth MacFarlane's Family
Guy what a cartoon later known as the
cartoon cartoon show was very atypical
at the time and its approach to
showcasing new short animated projects
every new episode was a Looney tune
length 7 minutes short that almost
always featured a new cartoon from a
different creator this cultivated
creativity as there was virtually no
interference from the executives at the
network and the creators of the shorts
had a lot of control over their projects
so what a cartoon show sits at the
foundation of Cartoon Network and
contributed many things to its identity
and legacy without this showcase for new
projects who knows what Cartoon Network
would look like today then such a high
number of the shorts first shown here
became so popular as their own
properties what a cartoon later changed
its format at the tail end of the 90s
and into the early 2000 the original 48
shorts all broadcasts in the 90s gave
creators some real power to put their
best shot at an original cartoon on a
national stage whenever I would see
these pop up as a kid I made sure to pay
attention because they were always so
different from anything else I watched
at the time the original Courage the
Cowardly Dog short the chicken from
outer space was even nominated for an
Oscar and I remember it vividly
you can find a lot of these shorts
online so I'd encourage you to go check
some of these out for yourself number
three
[Music]
man I'm pretty
Johnny Bravo centers around is titular
character and the often hilariously bad
situations he ends up in while in
pursuit of the opposite sex who usually
reject him in violent ways fairly
oddparents creator Butch Hartman and
Family Guy creator Seth MacFarlane both
worked on the show in its first season
and you can see some of their style
present in a few of those episodes
Johnny Bravo's eldest like voice and
personality mixed with the somewhat
absurd nature of the show created a
pretty iconic character that a lot of
people still recognize today there were
a lot of moments in the show's early run
where it felt like a classic cartoon and
that appeals in combination with some
veiled adult humor thrown in attractive
and awareness from an older audience Oh
Friday 9:00 yep loosey goosey loosey
goosey I challenge you to the king of
the beach competition did you say loosey
goosy apparently there was a 2011 TV
movie release called Johnny Bravo goes
to Bollywood that I had no idea existed
before recently researching this show
has anyone seen it how is it Johnny
Bravo was a staple of 90s and early
2000s cartoon network that people still
remember what more can you ask for
adios Johnny Bravo number 2
[Music]
Powerpuff Girls became a phenomenon in
the late 90s and early 2000 it was the
first short on the what a cartoon show
then went all the way to a theatrically
released movie in 2002 and was just
rebooted with a new series last year
Blossom Bubbles and Buttercup are
created when professor utonium attempts
to create the perfect little girl
but accidentally add chemical X to the
concoction-- thus the pop up girls are
bond they defend Townsville from
supernatural threats such as giant
monsters him and their nemesis Mojo Jojo
I loved Powerpuff Girls when it
originally aired in the 90s it wasn't
just a show that pandered to little
girls they never felt too cutesy to me
or anything like that
it was badass the Powerpuff Girls had
some awesome action and I had a blast
watching the show while the Powerpuff
Girls themselves professor utonium the
mayor of Townsville and miss bellum were
all really fun characters the show is
just as well known for its great
assortment of villains I know everyone
loves Mojo Jojo myself included but the
villain him was scary as hell
he was my favorite adversary for the
girls this is a village so evil so
sinister so horribly filed that even the
utterance of his name's likes fear into
the hearts of men the only safe way to
refer to this king of Darkness is simply
him
also the Rowdyruff Boys episode is still
burned in my memory the girls distinct
personality is always shine through and
made the episodes form to watch even
when they weren't fighting bad guys the
cultural impact of the show is
undeniable and still being felt at it I
haven't seen the rebooted series yet is
it worth a look let me know in the
comments Cartoon Network laid the
groundwork for what it is today in the
90s but it had to take a few risks to
get there thus not all those old
cartoons are winners so before we get to
number one here are a few honorable
mentions
[Music]
and the number one best 90s Cartoon
Network show is
[Music]
I wanted to mention that I really wanted
to include Courage the Cowardly Dog in
this but only five episodes aired in the
90 in the Nicktoons list I did include
season one of SpongeBob since most of it
came out in 99 but I just couldn't
legitimize throwing five episodes of the
Courage series in on here just know I
love that where'd will show now Dexter's
Lab is immediately what comes to mind
when I think of Cartoon Network original
shows from back in the day
Dexter is a genius boy with a hidden lab
in his room his sister DeeDee constantly
interrupts his experiments and often
causes mishaps to happen his ultimate
enemy Mandark a fellow young genius who
Dexter also clashes with on a regular
basis Dexter also had great reoccurring
additional segments of the show dial M
for monkey and the Justice friends the
talent behind Dexter's Lab basically
guaranteed his success creator Jenny
Tartakovsky is pretty prolific in the
world of animation in addition to Dexter
he was behind the creation of Samurai
Jack the 2d Star Wars Clone Wars show
and directed the Hotel Transylvania film
other people who worked on the show
included Seth MacFarlane and Butch
Hartman who are also on Johnny Bravo and
Powerpuff Girls creator craig mccracken
the show itself was fun funny and clever
it's also packed with memorable moments
and lines that I and a lot of kids I
knew imitated quite often yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes you are seated and don't
forget you are terrific the original run
of Dexter culminated in a TV movie in
1999 called ego trip and I remember
thinking how smart I thought it was even
back then we can't talk about Dexter
without mentioning dial M for monkey Wow
[Music]
the Justice friends was pretty funny as
well but monkey was almost as memorable
as Dexter himself you have the choice to
see the most glorious of gifts
opportunity to face cream-- great
wrathful or in a contest strength and
skill that episode is amazing go find
and watch wrath Lord oh yeah it was
pretty close between Dexter and
Powerpuff Girls but Dexter proved to be
the more memorable and slightly higher
quality show for me Cartoon Network was
a great alternative to Nickelodeon's
Nicktoons in the 90s and I enjoyed going
back and forth between the two these
shows are finally remembered by the kids
who watch them I want to hear what you
guys think what is your favorite 90s
Cartoon Network show what do you want me
to cover next on this show leave a
comment and let me know make sure you
check out awesome comics from yesterday
where we take a look at the worst Marvel
villains there are some bad ones I mean
big follow me on twitter at awesome
underscore walter to take part in more
polls about what i may cover in the
future come back next week when we
change things up yet again
on a brand new episode of top 5
[Music]
[Applause]
you